Spectacular, isn't it?
Probably.
What is it?
I've created a simulation of the entire universe.
Oh, in that case, it stinks.
I keep forgetting, Professor, are we in the entire universe?
Why, naturally.
Good news everyone, we've got a delivery!
Woo hoo!
But first, role call.
Leela.
Here.
Fry.
Present.
Scruffy.
Here.
Hermes!
Check.
Bender!
Bite my shiny metal pixel.
Amy.
Schmallviously.
And the rest.
Yay, I'm an unnamed member of the group!
That's amazing, Professor.
How'd you make it so crummy?
It wasn't easy. Even to achieve
this level of realism requires vast amounts of computing
power. My simpleton uses more electricity
than a hundred bug zappers. Which reminds me,
I had to unplug our bug zappers.
Oh!
Got him!
The mosquito is still alive.
There's a mosquito?